there's got to be a way out of this
dying
there's nothing can stop that
[Music]
V
my name is Songbird
I'm an nus intelligence analyst
I know about the bomb ticket in your
head
and I can save your life
what's the catch
we need you to get to Dogtown
attention all dog Town residents
president managed to crash her space
Force One into our humble District man's
got a thousand and one reasons to want
Myers as a hostage sleeper agents time
to wake them up so nusas tossing us back
into The Fray huh station we're in the
Wolves then now
get Myers out of there time to eat back
her safety is the top priority
they catch us out here we're dead
wait hear that God almighty
quick
[Music]
and ratted us up you know the treason
ain't never black and white it's a
charade V wherever she goes people get
hurt bodies drop just one word Songbird
promised me
I care
the situation has changed you need to
know if you're with me illusion of
Freedom draws in the desperate Pick Your
Truth be come on got iron in your head
you've got to put it to someone's head
pull the trigger
do anything and do it soon I'll die
thank you